It's okay, it's just a
little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of
Hmmm  It's okay, it's a sizzling feeling.It's
not particularly beyond the rental girlfriend.
Terushina
ban
I see, I understand the situation I'm really
embarrassed, but I'm always at the last minute and
I'm sorry What is it?
ー Do your best in Xining from this month It's always amazing
[Music] The
other party is a rental girlfriend.
I already have a girlfriend, so I don't need to rely on Chizuru-san.
Or should I say, Shisuru-san and I don't know if luck can be said quickly, right?
do you want
i have him